welcome to GameSpot gameplay will reshow
you the best games of the day so you can
make up your own mind
in the previous shadow of mordor routes
were always an apex predator to be
feared and sometimes subjugated but to
quote a really bad Star Wars movie
there's always a bigger fish in this
case shadow of war now has elemental
grogs Kara Gore's and Drake's that you
can summon onto the battlefield if you
invest in the right skill tree watch us
find a captain who's afraid of fire
call in a grog and you can probably
guess what happens next if you guess the
captain cheats death well you're just
gonna have to watch to find out give us
the old thumbs up and subscribe to our
channel so that we can let you know when
we have more shadow war coverage let's
get to it
[Music]
none fly all this racket just for little
old human you should feel special we're
all here to kill you
[Music]
[Applause]
you seem to hesitate on the start
critique me later
we've hi I faced countless Rangers in my
time and I've slaughtered them all you
can see all the trophies are taken from
them all Rangers must die and die ugly
instrumental their tests rockstar
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we know sent a spy to infiltrate
our ranks he'll be found out soon enough
[Music]
you miserable maggots stop crawling
around don't you men have spines get up
you're not what the nips you put my
blade